the church is supposed to direct the  government the government wait a second  which church there's like a thousand  that's supposed to direct the church  that is not how our founding fathers  intended it and i'm tired of this  separation of church and state junk  that's not in the constitution it was in  a stinking letter and it means nothing  like what they say it does  [Music]  now  which church is supposed to direct the  government because there are major  differences between say baptists  and pentecostals and born-again  christians or evangelicals or catholics  or whatever never mind right like  jews muslims atheists okay  this is full-fledged christian  nationalism it's dystopian and it's  dangerous and most importantly it's not  true